Prima di cominciare,
una comunicazione di servizio.
Dopo TEDx, per chi fosse interessato,
qua dietro le quinte
c'è una macchina del tempo.
Ed io, se vi fidate, so pilotarla.
(Risate)
Dove vorreste andare?
Beh, io sono un poeta,
un narratore teatrale
quindi, dipendesse da me,
ho certe idee molto chiare in testa
che magari dipendono
anche un po' dalla mia attività.
Io andrei in posti tipo, non so,
la Londra del 1600
a vedere la prima
dell'Amleto di Shakespeare,
con regia di Shakespeare.
E con Shakespeare
che fa anche una particina:
recita nella parte del fantasma.
Oppure l'Atene del V secolo avanti Cristo,
a vedere la prima
dell'Edipo Re di Sofocle,
con regia di Sofocle.
O la Firenze del XIV secolo,
a vedere Giovanni Boccaccio che legge
e commenta la Divina Commedia di Dante.
C'è l'imbarazzo della scelta,
o meglio ci sarebbe
l'imbarazzo della scelta,
se si trattasse di andare a fare,
come dire, una gita.
Cioè andiamo, vediamo lo spettacolino
e torniamo a casa.
Se invece si trattasse
di trasferirsi in pianta stabile
per alcuni mesi o alcuni anni,
io non avrei nessun dubbio
e penso che non dovreste averne
neanche voi.
Si va sicuramente tutti insieme a Parigi
negli anni '20 del XX secolo.
Una quantità compresente,
incredibile, di talenti artistici,
ma cosa dico di talenti, di geni.
Guardate chi c'era, guardate
chi avremmo potuto incontrare.
C'è questo signore qui:
Pablo Picasso.
Salvador Dalì.
Tutti lì sono.
Poi c'è questo signore qui,
che non andava sempre in giro così,
Man Ray,
è l'autore di questa foto molto famosa.
Qui è assieme Dalì.
Scrittori di un qualche talento:
Ernest Hemingway,
Fracis Scott Fitzgerald,
l'autore del Grande Gastby.
Poi c'è lui con la benda,
James Joyce,
l'autore dell'incredibile,
straordinariamente sperimentale,
"Ulisse".
E poi c'è questo signore qui,
Ezra Pound.
Due parole su questo signore.
È un un poeta statunitense.
Scriverà una opera
considerata uno dei capolavori
del XX secolo in poesia,
i "Cantos".
Sono 116 canti dove lui tenta
una sperimentazione folle con la lingua.
Sono scritti in inglese,
ma con innesti in latino, greco antico,
francese, cinese.
Traduceva dal cinese!
Ma Ezra Pound non è soltanto
un grandissimo artista,
è anche una specie di faro,
di punto di riferimento
per le altre menti geniali
che sono lì con lui.
Sarà lui a presentare
a James Joyce, Sylvia Beach,
che diventerà la sua editrice.
Ernest Hemingway, futuro premio Nobel,
dirà di Pound:
"Be'h ci siamo insegnanti
a vicenda qualcosa,
perché io ho insegnato a lui
a tirare di boxe
e lui ha insegnato a me
cosa scrivere o non scrivere".
Ah beh allora...
(Risate)
Vi confesso, era un gran bell'ambiente,
ma fra tutti quelli
che mi premerebbe più di incontrare,
beh, beh beh,
sarebbe proprio lui, Ezra Pound.
Ora naturalmente è bello fantasticare,
è bellissimo fantasticare
di macchine del tempo, eccetera,
ma sappiamo tutti
che le macchine del tempo non esistono,
né qui dietro,
né in nessun altro luogo al mondo
e probabilmente non esisteranno mai.
E l'unico modo per avere un rapporto
col passato
è studiarlo.
Ora io, studiando quest'epoca
straordinaria e informandomi,
ho imparato una cosa che non conoscevo
e mi ha lasciato molto perplesso,
molto perplesso.
Cioè che ad un certo punto,
e più precisamente nel 1925,
uno di questi qua,
uno di questi abitatori
del paradiso terrestre
-- chiamiamolo così --
se ne è andato via.
È andato via da Parigi.
Ma chi? Chi ha fatto una cosa del genere?
Eh, lui, Ezra Pound.
E dove è andato?
Eh... dove è andato?
Dove è venuto? Vorrete dire.
È venuto qua in Italia.
Perché Ezra Pound
era un grande conoscitore della storia,
era innamorato del passato,
ma una cosa lo ossessionava,
lo appassionava più di tutte le altre.
Il Rinascimento italiano.
E dunque Ezra Pound è qui in Italia
e va a visitare le città
che sono state protagoniste
del Rinascimento
e che lui ha citato nei Cantos.
O meglio nei primi
sedici canti dei Cantos,
gli unici che esistono
in quel momento, 1925.
E fra queste città ce n'è una
che lui non ha mai visto di persona
ma ha citato quattro volte.
Quattro volte nei canti
dall'ottavo all'undicesimo,
con una media di una volta per canto.
È la città in cui sono nato io 39 anni fa
e in cui voi adesso vi trovate:
Cesena.
(Applausi)
Cosa c'è a Cesena?
Anno di grazia 1454,
viene aperta al pubblico
la Biblioteca Malatestiana.
È la prima biblioteca
civica del mondo.
La prima biblioteca civica del mondo.
Esistevano altre biblioteche,
più antiche, ma erano private,
di monasteri, di signori.
Quella biblioteca è aperta al pubblico.
Ogni biblioteca civica
che è oggi sulla terra
ha quella biblioteca come antenata,
in senso letterale,
nel senso letterario,
nel senso che è nata prima.
Ora, cos'è una biblioteca?
È un luogo dove si accumula
molta, molta cura.
La cura degli amanuensi
di copiare un codice,
la cura degli studiosi,
degli umanisti di capire esattamente
il significato di un testo,
la cura dei custodi, ovviamente.
Ma ad un certo punto
a Cesena ha fatto irruzione qualcosa
che aveva molta poca cura:
la rivoluzione napoleonica.
Napoleone in persona
è entrato a Cesena a cavallo
e i suoi soldati hanno fatto strame
della Biblioteca,
nel senso che hanno tolto
dalla stanza i libri,
tolto i banchi,
squarciato i muri
per fare finestre più grandi,
in cui passasse più luce, più aria.
Una profanazione.
Ma negli anni '20, nel XX secolo,
il direttore di allora,
che si chiamava Manlio Torquato Dazzi,
ha fatto un'opera straordinaria
di recupero e restauro,
un'opera di grande, grandissima cura.
Ha chiuso le finestre moderne,
ha fatto restaurare quelle antiche,
ha restaurato e riportato dentro i banchi
e, soprattutto, i libri.
Quando arriva Ezra Pound a Cesena
è lui che lo accoglie,
lui gli mostra la Malatestiana,
com'era in principio,
com'era 500 anni prima.
Gli fa una specie di visita guidata
di un quarto d'ora.
Un salto di un quarto d'ora,
500 anni indietro nel tempo.
Gli mostra questo.
Ora, immagino che molti fra voi
siano stati nella parte antica
della Biblioteca Malatestiana,
che ovviamente nel frattempo
è stata ampliata.
Questa parte ora viene chiamata
l'aula del Nuti, dal nome dell'architetto.
Sapete tutti che questa foto
non rende giustizia.
È qualcosa di veramente
impressionante trovarsi lì.
È emozionante.
Sembra che da un momento all'altro
possa entrare un umanista del '500
e mettersi a studiare.
E Manlio Torquato Dazzi mostra
questa cosa a Ezra Pound,
l'uomo innamorato del passato,
l'uomo che aveva citato
quattro volte Cesena
senza neppur averla mai vista.
Ma il colpo di grazia è un altro.
Manlio Torquato Dazzi prende Ezra Pound
e gli mostra un'incisione sul muro.
"Vede, Signor Pound,
ci sono nove lettere incise:
L, U, C, R, E, T, I, A, B - Lucretia B.
Ora signor Pound la mia ipotesi
è che questa sia la firma di Lucrezia Borgia,
altro personaggio leggendario
del Rinascimento italiano.
Cosa era successo?
Gennaio del 1502,
Lucrezia Borgia ha 21 anni,
va da Roma a Ferrara per sposare
il suo terzo marito, Alfonso d'Este.
Fa tappa a Cesena
dove regnava suo fratello,
Cesare Borgia, Granduca di Romagna.
Entra a Cesena, dicono le cronache,
con una scorta di mille cavalieri,
seguiti da 150 muli che portano la dote.
Oro, gemme, vesti preziose.
Suonano le campane, sparano i cannoni.
Cento bambini vestiti
di giallo e di porpora,
i colori araldici dei Borgia,
le corrono incontro
portando ciascuno un rametto d'ulivo.
Visita la città e, ovviamente,
visita la Biblioteca Malatestiana,
il luogo più prezioso della città,
e, secondo Manlio Torquato Dazzi,
lascia la sua firma
come una qualsiasi ragazzina.
È sconvolto,
è veramente affascinato, Ezra Pound,
da questa cosa.
Decide di fare un regalo,
un regalo alla città di Cesena.
Porta in dono alla Malatestiana un libro.
Una edizione fuori commercio,
limitatissima,
dei sedici canti che ha scritto finora.
Scrive di suo pugno,
in italiano, una dedica:
"Nel tempo che il suo amico
Manlio Dazzi era bibliotecario,
Ezra Pound portava questo libro in dono
a la Malatestiana in segno di amicizia.
26/5/1925 - E.P, Ezra Pound".
E poco sotto, nella stessa pagina,
con una scrittura leggermente più minuta,
Manlio Torquato Dazzi annota:
"L'originale è fuori commercio,
in 80 copie, non depositata
né presso la Biblioteca Nazionale
di Parigi, né presso quella di Londra,
ma unicamente presso
la Malatestiana di Cesena,
per l'interesse dei canti malatestiani.
M. T. D. Manlio Torquato Dazzi"
Scusate non è una grande fotografia,
lo so, l'ho fatta io.
(Risate)
Però Ezra Pound
chiede un favore a Dazzi,
che il suo libro sia lasciato
lì insieme agli altri,
insieme ai codici antichi,
lì nella parte rinascimentale,
nell'aula del Nuti.
Di fronte a questa richiesta,
di un artista così grande,
Manlio Torquato Dazzi dice:
"No".
(Risate)
Come "No"?
"No".
La Biblioteca Malatestiana,
l'aula del Nuti, deve essere esattamente
com'era 500 anni fa,
e non sono permesse intrusioni,
per quanto illustri.
Ma Ezra Pound è un grande poeta!
"No".
Ma si parla di Cesena, in quel poema
che farà la storia della poesia!
"No".
In nome della perfetta filologia,
in nome della cura,
in nome della dedizione:
"No".
È la fine di un'amicizia?
(Risate)
"No".
Ezra Pound e Manlio Torquato Dazzi
si scriveranno per tutta la vita
e nei cento canti
che scriverà successivamente
Ezra Pound citerà Cesena altre tre volte.
E in una di queste tre volte citerà
quell'episodio, quel quarto d'ora favoloso
in cui ha visitato la Malatestiana,
scrivendo, nel canto 74
--scusate la pronuncia--
"Came madame Lucretia and on the back
of the door in Cesena are,
or were still the initials,
joli quart d'heure nella Malatestiana,
Torquato, where art thou?"
Che vuol dire più o meno:
"È venuta madame Lucrezia"
--cioè Lucrezia Borgia--
"e dietro la porta a Cesena ci sono,
o perlomeno c'erano ancora le iniziali,
che bel quarto d'ora"
--in francese--
"nella Malatestiana"
--in italiano--
"Torquato"
--cioè Manlio Torquato Dazzi--
"dove sei?"
--in inglese arcaico--
(Risate)
Insomma, se io avessi
una macchina del tempo
andrei là nella Parigi
del XX secolo e degli anni '20,
anche se in realtà chi era là
se ne è andato via,
per rimanere meravigliato,
stupefatto, attonito,
davanti al luogo in cui ci troviamo noi.
(Applausi)
Se volete vedere il dono
che il poeta ha fatto a Cesena, potete.
Ovviamente non è nell'aula del Nuti,
è in una cassaforte,
ma chiunque faccia richiesta può vederlo,
vedere le sue pagine di carta pregiata,
gli incipit decorati,
che sono diversi ad ogni canto,
e soprattutto vedere con i vostri occhi
la dedica commossa di Pound
e la nota del grande,
granitico, Torquato Dazzi.
(Risate)
Sarete condotti, come me,
in una stanza dove, in un tavolo vicino,
alcuni restauratori si prendono cura
dei testi antichi, dei codici medievali.
Così lì, fra le vostre mani,
il libro di Pound,
mi piace pensare,
potrà sentire l'odore di quei libri,
udire il frusciare
delle loro pagine di pergamena
e sognare di trovarsi là, con loro,
dove aveva sperato di essere ammesso.
Penso che ne sarà felice.
(Applausi)